Your know who Studs Terkel is? I think a lot of people, especially if you're younger, you read him in school-- his books, Division Street and Working and The Good War . He was an oral historian. But from 1952 to 1997, he also did a radio show on WMFT in Chicago, where he would broadcast the interviews that ended up in his books, and also lots of interviews with famous musicians and actors and artists. Anyway, I was going through some old tapes of his radio show recently for this event they had celebrating his life. And I stumbled across this utterly ordinary, nothing-special-going-on Friday on his radio program. Anyway, here's Studs.
你知道Studs Terkel是谁吗？我想很多人，特别是年轻人，在学校里读过他的书——比如《分区街》（Division Street）、《工作》（Working）和《好战争》（The Good War）。他是一位口述历史学家。但在1952年到1997年间，他还在芝加哥的WMFT电台主持一档广播节目，在那里他会播出那些最终被收录进他书中的采访，以及许多对著名音乐家、演员和艺术家的采访。总之，最近为了一个庆祝他生平的活动，我在翻看他广播节目的一些旧录音带。我偶然发现了他在节目中一个极其普通、平平无奇的周五。总之，这就是Studs。
I think it's pretty obvious to readers that Mike Royko's column is not only witty, but I think it's journalism in the true sense, in digging into--
我想读者们都很清楚，Mike Royko的专栏不仅风趣幽默，而且我认为那是真正意义上的新闻报道，深入挖掘——
It's a Friday in July nearly 50 years ago. It's July 29, 1966. And his guest that day is a good friend of his, newspaper columnist Mike Royko, another iconic Chicago figure. Anyway, on this particular day, they kill two hours very interestingly, I have to say, chatting about stories in the news.
那是近50年前七月的一个周五，1966年7月29日。那天他的嘉宾是他的好朋友、报纸专栏作家Mike Royko，另一位标志性的芝加哥人物。总之，在那特别的一天，不得不说，他们非常有趣地消磨了两个小时，聊着新闻里的故事。
The medical director of Cook County hospital, for example, had made headlines when he said that he did not need to air condition the operating rooms in the facility. Surgeons, he said, should instead eat salted crackers, which would replace the salt that doctors lose when they sweat. There was some news that week about the prize fighter they still called Cassius Clay. There was a story that was national news at the time that I would be very surprised if you heard of. I had not heard of this.
例如，库克县医院的医疗主任在说他不需要给医院的手术室安装空调时上了头条。他说外科医生应该多吃咸饼干，这样可以补充医生出汗流失的盐分。那一周还有一些关于那位当时仍被称为Cassius Clay的拳击手的新闻。当时还有一个全国性的新闻故事，如果你们听说过我会非常惊讶。我自己之前没听说过。
Basically, a justice on the Supreme Court, William O. Douglas, a liberal appointed by FDR who'd been on the bench almost three decades at that point-- the news was he had gotten married. Here's Studs talking to Mike Royko about that.
基本上，最高法院大法官William O. Douglas，一位由富兰克林·罗斯福总统任命的自由派，当时已经在任近三十年了——新闻是他结婚了。下面是Studs和Mike Royko谈论这件事。
And you did a column, I understand, received quite a response. What happened in Congress, the objections of many-- Pat, I think this is worth reading.
我听说你写了一篇专栏，反响很大。国会里发生了什么，许多人的反对——Pat，我觉得这值得一读。
Mhm.
嗯。
May I read this one? Because this leads, I know, to all sorts of discussion.
我可以读这一篇吗？因为我知道，这会引出各种各样的讨论。
OK, I'm just going to stop the tape right there. For whatever reason, Royko seems to prefer that Studs read his columns on this show, rather than read them out loud himself. And if it's OK with you, I enjoyed this next bit, and I know that you tuned in just now to hear a radio show made, you know, today, but let's just do a little time travel, OK?
好的，我就在这儿暂停录音。不管出于什么原因，Royko似乎更喜欢让Studs在节目中读他的专栏，而不是他自己大声读出来。如果你们不介意的话，我挺喜欢接下来的这一段，我知道你们刚才调到这里是想听一个“今天”制作的广播节目，但让我们稍微做个时间旅行，好吗？
So your radio or your computer or your smartphone or whatever picks up instead a radio show from 1966 for just a couple minutes. And let's enjoy this together. Here's Studs.
所以你们的收音机、电脑、智能手机或其他什么设备，会在这几分钟里播放1966年的广播节目。让我们一起来享受吧。这就是Studs。
And Mike writes, "a ringing dissent to criticism of Justice Douglas. When Associate Justice William O. Douglas returns from his honeymoon, it would be perfectly proper for him to do the following-- walk with great dignity to his seat on the Supreme Court bench, sit down, draw his black robes about him, slowly raise  is right hand, touch the tip of his thumb to the tip of his nose, wiggle his fingers."
Mike写道：“对批评Douglas大法官的言论表示强烈反对。当威廉·O·道格拉斯大法官度完蜜月回来时，他做以下行为是完全得体的——庄重地走到他在最高法院的席位上，坐下，披上他的黑袍，慢慢举起右手，用拇指尖触碰鼻尖，摆动手指。”
OK, just pausing that again. Have you got what he's describing there? OK, good.
好的，再暂停一下。明白他描述的动作了吗？好的，很好。
"Now, this would provide a fitting message and ensure an explanation for the busybodies of America, who currently are wallowing in indignation, their favorite puddle. The busybodies are upset because Douglas, 67, married Cathleen Heffernan, 23. It was his fourth marriage, and she is his youngest bride."
“现在，这将提供一个恰当的信息，并给美国的那些好事者一个解释，他们目前正沉浸在义愤填膺的泥潭中，这是他们最喜欢的泥潭。好事者们很不满，因为67岁的道格拉斯娶了23岁的Cathleen Heffernan。这是他的第四次婚姻，而她是她最年轻的新娘。”
The issue here, in Royko's opinion, is whether this is really anybody's business at all-- which is, incidentally, the subject of today's radio show, our radio show, when to mind your own business.
在Royko看来，这里的问题是这到底是否与任何人有关——顺便说一句，这正是今天广播节目的主题，我们的广播节目，什么时候该管好你自己的事。
"The fact that a man they don't know married a girl they don't know, for reasons that are none of anyone else's business, has a terrible effect on the tempers of many people. Why this is, I don't know."
“一个他们不认识的人娶了一个他们不认识的女孩，理由与任何人无关，这事实对许多人的脾气产生了可怕的影响。为什么会这样，我不知道。”
Royko's column then quotes some things that he heard somebody say about the marriage on a Chicago call-in show. And then Royko turns to Congress, where a Democrat from Alabama called for a congressional investigation into Douglas's character because of this marriage, and said that he had heard that Douglas had been cruel to his previous wives. A congressman from Mississippi said that of all the courts troublesome decisions recently, this decision, to head down the quote, "highway of matrimony," has raised the most eyebrows.
Royko的专栏接着引用了他从芝加哥的一个电话连线节目中听到的一些人对这次婚姻的评论。然后Royko转向国会，那里的一位来自阿拉巴马州的民主党人因为这次婚姻呼吁对道格拉斯的品格进行国会调查，并说他听说道格拉斯对前任妻子很残忍。一位来自密西西比州的国会议员说，在法院最近所有麻烦的判决中，这个踏上所谓“婚姻高速公路”的决定，最令人侧目。
"And Representative Paul Finley, Republican of Illinois, said there should be a way to remove a justice from the bench without a trial for crimes or misdemeanors."
“伊利诺伊州的共和党众议员Paul Finley说，应该有一种无需审判即可罢免大法官职务的方法，即使没有犯罪或轻罪。”
OK, seriously, hearing this today, with the distance of a half century, this controversy feels so utterly about nothing-- so inconsequential. It makes you wonder, is this what the Anthony Weiner story is going to sound like, a half century from now? And yeah, OK, maybe it's a little icky for a 67-year-old to marry a 23-year-old, but these, you know, are consenting adults. These are people who are doing nothing against the laws of the United States of America, nothing that seems to merit congressional action. Anyway, Royko's column ends with several questions, he says, remain unanswered.
好吧，说真的，今天听到这些，隔了半个世纪，这种争议感觉完全没什么大不了——太不重要了。这让人怀疑，五十年后，Anthony Weiner的故事听起来会是怎样的？好吧，也许让一个67岁的人娶一个23岁的人确实有点令人不适，但他们，你知道，是成年人，双方自愿。他们没有做任何违反美利坚合众国法律的事，也没有任何看起来值得国会采取行动的事。总之，Royko的专栏以几个悬而未决的问题结束。
"How many marriages will a justice be allowed before he gets kicked off the bench? What will be an acceptable age difference in the marriage of a justice to a younger woman? Will a justice be permitted to marry an older woman?
“一位大法官在被踢出法官席之前，被允许结婚多少次？大法官与年轻女性结婚，可接受的年龄差是多少？大法官被允许娶比他年长的女性吗？”
What does the Alabama congressman consider cruelty to a wife? Are tear gas, billy clubs, police dogs, and shotguns acceptable on the highway of matrimony, or only on the highway back home?"
“阿拉巴马州的国会议员认为什么是对妻子的残忍？催泪瓦斯、警棍、警犬和猎枪在婚姻高速公路上是可以接受的，还是只在回家的路上？”
[COUGHS]
[咳嗽]
Well, naturally, something happened here--
嗯，很自然地，这里发生了一些事——
[COUGHS] Yeah.
[咳嗽] 是的。
--when you wrote this.
——当你写这篇文章的时候。
Yeah. People got mad. The response was almost unanimously against my position.
是的。人们很生气。反应几乎是一致反对我的立场。
Now, what sort of madness?
那么，是哪种疯狂？
I wasn't surprised. Oh, well, there were some very funny letters. I found out that apparently more people are concerned about the Supreme Court justice's marriage than they are about what he does the rest of the time that he's on the bench.
我不感到惊讶。哦，好吧，有一些非常有趣的信。我发现显然有更多的人关心最高法院大法官的婚姻，而不是关心他在法官席上其余时间所做的事情。
One woman wrote me a letter and said that she surely wouldn't vote for him the next time he ran for election.
一位女士给我写了一封信，说她下次选举时肯定不会投他的票。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
[LAUGHS] I don't think she'd heard of him before. And--
[笑声] 我想她在那之前可能没听说过他。而且——
This next part of the recording I really just love. They haul in staffers at the radio station-- basically just grab them from down the hall-- to read some of the letters that Royko got after he wrote this column.
录音的接下来这一部分我真的很喜欢。他们把电台的工作人员叫来——基本上就是从走廊里把他们抓过来——读一些Royko写完这篇专栏后收到的信件。
So now we got-- here are letters in response to Mike Royko's column, if we may start. And then Mike, perhaps, you could read your comment. You have a little comment at the end of each one.
所以现在我们有——这是回应Mike Royko专栏的信件，如果我们能开始的话。然后Mike，也许你可以读你的评论。你在每一封信的最后都有一个小评论。
No, you read it.
不，你来读。
No, you do-- no, the comment.
不，你来——不，评论部分。
I-- I can't read it.
我——我读不了。
All right. So I will be Mike Royko. This is Jimmy Jake, an older man. However, you read. This is Jake, here.
好吧。那我来做Mike Royko。这是Jimmy Jake，一位老人。不过，你来读。这是Jake。
"It is hard to believe that you were serious in your column about Justice Douglas. I'm 62. And ever since I read about this bit, I've been trying to figure out how I could tactfully and with justification approach some or even one of the cute young things that populate the building I'm in. No matter how I phrase my approach, I seem to hear the same words. 'Why, you dirty old man.' Now then, this makes me wonder, how does a 67-year-old man make the approach?"
“很难相信你在关于道格拉斯大法官的专栏中是认真的。我62岁了。自从我读到这个消息，我就一直在想怎么能得体地、有理由地接近我所在大楼里那些可爱的年轻姑娘。无论我怎么表达，我似乎总是听到同样的话：‘你这个肮脏的老头。’那么，这让我怀疑，一个67岁的人是怎么接近对方的？”
"Oh, well, I assume he said something like, will you marry me? What have you been thinking of saying?"
“哦，好吧，我假设他说了类似‘你愿意嫁给我吗？’之类的话。你一直在想说什么？”
And then a girl named Jane was indignant. Kathy?
然后一个叫Jane的女孩很气愤。Kathy？
"You have an obligation to the reading public as well as to yourself to stick with the truth. And truth comes from God. And what has Justice Douglas done with God's commandments? People disgustingly, and rightly so, talk about Liz Taylor. Douglas is just one step behind her, making a mockery of marriage.
“你对阅读大众和对自己都有义务坚持真理。真理来自上帝。道格拉斯大法官把上帝的诫命置于何地？人们令人厌恶地，而且正确地谈论Liz Taylor。道格拉斯只比她落后一步，在嘲弄婚姻。”
Do you advocate what Liz Taylor has done? This country's laws are based on Christian doctrine and morality. And if a Supreme Court judge openly and continually disregards those laws, what is the common man to think about regarding the sanctity of marriage?"
“你主张Liz Taylor所做的事吗？这个国家的法律基于基督教教义和道德。如果最高法院法官公开且持续地无视这些法律，普通人会对婚姻的神圣性怎么想？”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Well--
嗯——
All right, I'm going to stop the tape there. I assume that they're laughing mostly because of the sheer moxie that their colleague is bringing to her performance of that letter. Studs is usually very tolerant of people's religious beliefs.
好了，我要在那儿暂停录音。我假设他们笑主要是因为他们的同事在读那封信时表现出的那种纯粹的勇气。Studs通常对人们的宗教信仰非常宽容。
Her letter does get to the heart of controversy, though. Douglas was a very liberal voice on the liberal Warren Court. And lots of conservatives saw this marriage as just another indication of permissive liberal values and what was wrong with the whole direction of the country in 1966. Anyway, here's one more letter.
不过，她的信确实触及了争议的核心。道格拉斯是自由派Warren法院中一个非常自由的声音。许多保守派认为这次婚姻只是自由派价值观放纵的又一迹象，也是1966年整个国家方向错误的表现。总之，还有一封信。
And finally, Marty Robinson was busy announcing. Now, Marty, you're a doctor in Oak Park.
最后，Marty Robinson在忙着发表意见。Marty，你是橡树园的医生。
"Now, your thinking in your Douglas column is the kind of fuzzy mindedness that is seized upon by many to do anything they wish in the name of freedom."
“你对道格拉斯专栏的想法，是那种被许多人打着自由的旗号利用来做任何他们想做的事的糊涂思想。”
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
Spoken like an authoritative doctor. And Mike replies, "Getting married four times isn't exactly my idea of having freedom." That's a good one. Thank you, ladies and gentlemen.
说得像个权威的医生。Mike回复道：“结四次婚并不完全是我心目中的自由。”说得好。谢谢大家。
Now, Mike, did you receive any letters praising you for the column?
Mike，你有没有收到任何赞扬你这篇专栏的信？
A couple of dirty old men liked it.
几个肮脏的老头喜欢它。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
Can I just say-- OK, it's annoying, the self-righteousness that people have in condemning this marriage, right? But it's also kind of harsh, the self-righteousness that Royko has in criticizing them. After all, like, sure, what happens in this marriage is nobody's business but their own.
我可以插一句吗——好吧，人们在谴责这段婚姻时表现出的自以为是令人讨厌，对吧？但Royko在批评他们时表现出的自以为是也有点刻薄。毕竟，确实，这段婚姻里发生了什么除了他们自己谁也不管。
But who among us, I would ask you, who among us hears about a 67-year-old man marrying somebody a third his age without feeling like a little twinge of judginess, right? Like, who doesn't have feelings about that? Who is above that?
但我想问你们，我们中间有谁听到一个67岁的人娶了一个年龄只有他三分之一的人，而不感到一点点评判的刺痛感呢？对吧？谁没有这种感觉？谁能凌驾于此？
Which is to say, it's hard minding your own business. We're human beings. We're programmed to make judgments about every situation that we walk into and hear about. It is hard not to be nosy. It is hard not to want to know more. That is being alive.
也就是说，管好自己的事很难。我们是人类。我们被编程为对我们进入和听到的每一个情况做出判断。很难不爱管闲事。很难不想知道更多。这就是生活。
And today on our program, we have stories of people not minding their own business. Well, actually, in these stories, it's big institutions not minding their business and busybodying their way into all kinds of stuff, into what kind of underwear is being worn by cheerleaders, into what is happening in jail hallways in cell blocks.
今天在我们的节目中，我们有关于人们没有管好自己事的故事。嗯，实际上，在这些故事中，是大型机构没有管好自己的事，并以“好事者”的方式介入了各种事情，介入啦啦队员穿什么样的内衣，介入监狱走廊牢房里发生的事情。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
来自WBEZ芝加哥，这是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。请继续收听。
Act One, Jill House Rules. In January of this year, a woman who went by the name of Lacy T filed a lawsuit against the Oakland raiders for failing to pay her minimum wage. Lacy was a cheerleader for the team, a rookie. NFL cheerleaders generally make about $1,500 for the entire season, although some make as little as $850 for the entire season.
第一幕，Jill的家规。今年一月，一位名叫Lacy T的女士对奥克兰突袭者队提起诉讼，指控他们没有支付她最低工资。Lacy是该队的啦啦队员，一名新人。NFL啦啦队员整个赛季通常收入约1500美元，尽管有些人整个赛季仅赚850美元。
Just a few weeks after Lacy, another cheerleader filed a suit, this one against the Cincinnati Bengals. Then, cheerleaders with the Buffalo Bills, New York Jets, Tampa Bay Buccaneers, women from five NFL cheerleaders teams were suing for higher pay. What's interesting is that the way the cheerleaders are trying to win is to argue that the teams exert so much control over their lives, they are so up in their business, that the cheerleaders deserve to be considered employees. If they are considered employees, then they have to be paid minimum wage.
在Lacy之后仅几周，另一位啦啦队员提起了诉讼，这次是针对辛辛那提孟加拉虎队。然后，布法罗比尔队、纽约喷气机队、坦帕湾海盗队的啦啦队员，来自五个NFL啦啦队团队的女性都在起诉要求更高的工资。有趣的是，啦啦队员们试图获胜的方式是辩称球队对她们的生活行使了如此多的控制权，以至于她们如此深入地干涉她们的事务，啦啦队员们值得被视为雇员。如果她们被视为雇员，那么她们就必须获得最低工资。
So the lawsuits also include a bunch of internal documents that describe how much up in their business the franchises are. Here's Chana Joffe-Walt.
所以诉讼还包括一堆内部文件，描述了球队对她们的生活干涉有多深。这是Chana Joffe-Walt的报道。
It was Page 18 that really got me, the Buffalo Jills lawsuit. The team is the Buffalo Bills, so the cheerleaders are the Jills. And on Page 18 of these legal documents, they're describing a Jills rulebook the team gives out to each squad member.
真正让我震惊的是第18页，关于布法罗Jills的诉讼。球队是布法罗比尔队，所以啦啦队员被称为Jills。在这些法律文件的第18页，他们描述了球队发给每位队员的Jills规则手册。
It says, quote, "The extensive rulebook set forth by defendants includes rules on how much bread to eat at a formal dinner, how to properly eat soup, how much to tip restaurant waiters, wedding etiquette, how to properly wash intimate areas, and how often to change tampons." And then, right here as evidence, they include the actual handbook-- the "glamour requirement section," two pages on conversation starters, 17 rules for what they call "general hygiene and lady body maintenance."
它写道，引用：“被告制定的详尽规则手册包括关于在正式晚宴上吃多少面包、如何正确喝汤、给餐厅服务员多少小费、婚礼礼仪、如何正确清洗私密部位以及多久更换一次卫生棉条的规定。”然后，就在这里作为证据，他们包括了实际手册——“魅力要求部分”，两页关于谈话开头的话题，17条关于他们所谓的“个人卫生和女性身体保养”的规则。
I think what's so bizarre about reading these rules as an outsider, someone who works in an office every day, is it's really hard to imagine your boss talking to you about this stuff. Let me show you what I mean with my boss. I asked my boss, Ira, to read some of these rules. Hey, Ira.
我想作为一个外人，一个每天在办公室工作的人，读到这些规则真是太不可思议了，真的很难想象你的老板跟你谈论这些事。让我通过我的老板演示一下我的意思。我请我的老板Ira读了一些这些规则。嘿，Ira。
Hey there, Chana.
嘿，Chana。
OK. So imagine your boss walking into your cubicle and saying--
好的。想象一下你的老板走进你的隔间说——
All right, here we go. "Stay away from frosted lipsticks and eye shadows. Management will determine your proper color analysis. No slouching breasts-- support as needed."
好吧，我们开始。“远离磨砂质地的口红和眼影。管理层将确定你正确的色彩分析。不得含胸驼背——必要时给予支撑。”
Yeah, that's weird.
是啊，那很怪。
That's weird.
那很怪。
Keep going, though. Keep going. So here are some more actual rules from actual cheerleader handbooks.
继续读下去。所以这里还有一些来自实际啦啦队员手册的实际规则。
"Never apply makeup or fuss with hair front of people. If it's absolutely necessary you reapply, freshen up, go to the ladies' room. And do not hang out and talk while there. Beware, other women will judge you in there, too. Always say excuse me when you burp, sneeze, or cough, even if you think there isn't anyone around.
“永远不要在人前化妆或整理头发。如果绝对需要重新化妆，去洗手间整理。不要在里面闲逛聊天。小心，其他女性也会在里面评判你。打嗝、打喷嚏或咳嗽时一定要说对不起，即使你认为周围没有人。”
Napkins-- when you leave the table at the end of the meal, place your napkin loosely next to your plate. It should not be crumpled or twisted, which would reveal untidiness or nervousness, respectively."
“餐巾——用餐结束离开餐桌时，将餐巾松散地放在盘子旁边。它不应该被揉皱或扭曲，这会分别显示出凌乱或紧张。”
There's a lot of rules about the cheerleaders' bodies, which I get. It's a job that depends on your body. But these rules get deep into your mind, like these ones. Read these, Ira.
有很多关于啦啦队员身体的规则，我明白。这是一份依赖你身体的工作。但这些规则深入到你的思想，比如这些。读一下这些，Ira。
OK. "Please, think before you speak and always pay attention and listen. Ask yourself, 'Is it likely that this person will be interested in what I'm about to bring up?' Do not be overly opinionated about anything.
好的。“请在说话前思考，并时刻注意倾听。问问自己，‘这个人会对我要提起的话题感兴趣吗？’不要对任何事情过于固执己见。”
Do not complain about anything. Ever hang out with a whiner? It's exhausting and boring. Watch other poor manners or nervous habits, such as nail biting, knuckle-slash-neck cracking, excessive sniffling, and too many arm movements."
“不要抱怨任何事情。曾经和爱抱怨的人待在一起吗？这既累人又无聊。注意其他糟糕的礼仪或紧张的习惯，比如咬指甲、掰关节/脖子、频繁吸鼻子和过多的手臂动作。”
I like imagining what the author was picturing with that last one. "Too many arm movements."
我喜欢想象作者写最后一条时脑海里在想什么。“过多的手臂动作。”
Yeah.
是啊。
OK. So I didn't really know what to make of these. It's hard to imagine the NFL players have handbooks that outline how to eat bread politely and wash their genitals. But I don't know. Maybe no cheerleaders actually talk about these rules, or no one enforces them. Maybe cheerleading manuals are essentially employee handbooks that nobody ever reads.
好吧。所以我真的不知道该怎么看待这些。很难想象NFL球员有规定如何礼貌地吃面包和清洗生殖器的手册。但我不知道。也许没有啦啦队员真的讨论这些规则，或者没有人执行它们。也许啦啦队手册本质上是没人读过的员工手册。
So I ran a bunch of them by a couple current and former cheerleaders, who told me, yeah, we had lots of rules like that. And we knew those rules. But most of them also added, the rules were not a big deal.
所以我向几位现任和前任啦啦队员询问了一些，她们告诉我，是的，我们确实有很多那样的规则。我们知道那些规则。但她们大多数人也补充说，这些规则没什么大不了的。
Carly Walko cheered for the Redskins and the Eagles.
Carly Walko曾为红皮队和老鹰队欢呼。
I mean, of course some of them were frustrating, like your nails a certain length or whatever. And, I mean, you just have to believe that every rule's there because there's been a circumstance in the past that has had to put it there. So you would think, nail length, who cares? Everyone keeps their nails relatively reasonably long.
我是说，当然其中一些令人沮丧，比如指甲长度之类的。而且，我的意思是，你只需要相信每一条规则的存在都是因为过去发生过某种不得不制定它的情况。所以你会想，指甲长度，谁在乎呢？每个人都把指甲保持在相对合理的长度。
There must have been some girl along the way who had like 8-inch nails and probably stabbed some girl in the back doing a lift or something. And so now they have to say you can't have your nails be past a certain point. Which seems silly, but someone 10 years ago got hurt on the field because a girl's nails were too long. Do you know what I'm saying?
肯定有哪个女孩一路走来留了8英寸长的指甲，可能在做托举动作时戳伤了某个女孩。所以现在他们必须说指甲不能超过某个长度。这看起来很傻，但10年前确实有人因为女孩指甲太长而在场上受伤了。你知道我的意思吗？
Other cheerleaders I talked to said the same thing. The rules may seem weird from the outside, but really, they're not. And they didn't have a problem with them.
其他我交谈过的啦啦队员也说了同样的话。这些规则从外面看可能很奇怪，但实际上并非如此。她们对这些规则没有意见。
But I wasn't confident that was a completely honest take. Cheerleaders, after all, are hired to promote their teams. That's their job. So even if they did find the rules stupid or way up in their business, why would they talk to some stranger about that on the radio?
但我并不确定这是一个完全诚实的看法。毕竟，啦啦队员是被雇佣来推广她们球队的。这是她们的工作。所以即使她们觉得这些规则很蠢或干涉太多，为什么要在广播里对陌生人说这些呢？
But I realized I do have someone to ask about these documents who knows this world and could speak with me honestly about it-- my colleague, This American Life producer Robyn Semien. Robyn was an NBA cheerleader.
但我意识到我确实有一个可以询问这些文件的人，她了解这个世界，并且可以诚实地与我谈论它——我的同事，This American Life制片人Robyn Semien。Robyn曾是一名NBA啦啦队员。
I had a great time on the Lakers. I really did. It was fun. It was fun.
我在湖人队度过了一段美好的时光。我真的觉得很有趣。很有趣。
Robyn was a Laker Girl in college. After 20 years of dance classes and cheer camps, she made it to the Lakers, which is a big deal. I feel like I need to say that, because Robyn will not. She made me ask three times before she told me she beat out hundreds of other women for her spot.
Robyn上大学时是湖人女孩。经过20年的舞蹈课和啦啦队训练营，她成功进入了湖人队，这可是件大事。我觉得我有必要提一下，因为Robyn自己不会说。她让我问了三次，才告诉我她击败了数百名其他女性才获得了这个位置。
In the end, it's 16 of us were chosen-- three brunettes and three blonds and two redheads, maybe. And so I was one of two black girls that were hired. So, like, I knew that this was just kind of-- that there were roles, that I was auditioning for a part. And that was fine.
最终，我们有16个人入选——可能是三个棕色头发的，三个金发的，两个红发的。我是被雇佣的两个黑人女孩之一。所以，我知道这只是某种——我有角色，我在为一个角色试镜。这没关系。
When I read the guidelines and handbooks to Robyn, she just kind of shrugged. We were there representing an enormous franchise, she told me. Of course there were rules about everything.
当我向Robyn读那些准则和手册时，她只是耸了耸肩。她告诉我，我们在那里代表一个庞大的特许经营权。当然关于一切都有规则。
Yeah, there were tons of rules. A main one was you can't date the players, which meant-- like, you can't date the players, which really meant you can't sleep with the players. But also you can't date them. But also you can't be seen anywhere alone with them. Like, you cannot-- there's just no crossover between what we are doing as the Laker Girls and what the Laker team was doing.
是的，规则成吨。主要的一条是你不能和球员约会，这意味着——比如，你不能和球员约会，实际上意味着你不能和球员上床。但你也不能和他们约会。而且你也不能在任何地方单独和他们一起被看到。就像，你不能——作为湖人女孩我们所做的和湖人队所做的事情之间没有任何交叉。
So you didn't have any relationships with any of the players.
所以你和任何球员都没有过任何关系。
None. I mean, none.
没有。我的意思是，完全没有。
Robyn says everyone knew that rule. And they didn't need to read it in a handbook, because they had Lisa. Lisa Estrada was and still is the director of the Laker Girls.
Robyn说每个人都知道那条规则。她们不需要在手册里读到它，因为她们有Lisa。Lisa Estrada是，现在仍然是湖人女孩的总监。
It was Lisa who told the squad which kind of lipstick to wear, how much, which mascara, how long their nails should be. It was Lisa who did weigh-ins before games. It was Lisa who told Robyn to straighten her hair so it'd look like Suzanne Somers from Three's Company . Lisa was a boss you remember.
正是Lisa告诉队员们涂哪种口红，涂多少，用哪种睫毛膏，指甲该留多长。是Lisa在比赛前进行体重检查。是Lisa告诉Robyn要把头发拉直，这样看起来就像《三人行》里的Suzanne Somers。Lisa是一个你会记住的老板。
She was-- I mean, she's a spitfire. And she was really funny, and also kind of really kind of scary. In my mind she was, like, spending all day every day like in some meeting with, like, Jerry Buss like the owner of the Lakers. Just she was always seeming to come from some important meeting or something important about our dances or our image or what the Lakers organization needed from us meant.
她——我的意思是，她是个火药桶。她真的很风趣，但也确实有点吓人。在我看来，她好像整天整天都在和Jerry Buss（湖人老板）开会。她总是看起来刚从某个重要的会议，或者是关于我们的舞蹈、我们的形象，或者是湖人组织需要我们做什么的会议中走出来。
When they went out on appearances-- say a Staples office supply store would want four Laker girls for their grand opening-- they would offer good money. And Lisa would say, you can go but--
当她们出去参加活动时——比如史泰博办公用品商店想要四个湖人女孩参加开业典礼——他们会提供不错的报酬。而Lisa会说，你们可以去，但是——
I expect that you all conduct yourselves appropriately. And don't ever forget what you're representing.
我期望你们所有人都举止得体。永远不要忘记你们代表着什么。
What were you representing?
你们代表着什么？
I don't-- um, class.
我不——嗯，阶级感。
You were classy.
你们很优雅。
Yes. Yeah, yeah.
是的。是啊，是啊。
Did you understand what that meant?
你明白那意味着什么吗？
Kind of. It just meant that we weren't slutty.
算是吧。这只是意味着我们不是那种轻浮的人。
There was a line. Lisa wanted the line to be blindingly bright. And that's what the rules were about. One side of the line was classy. The other side was slutty. Lisa wanted you to be on the right side of the line. And that made sense to Robyn.
有一条界限。Lisa想让这条界限亮得刺眼。这就是规则的意义所在。界限的一边是优雅。另一边是轻浮。Lisa想让你待在界限的右边。这对Robyn来说很有道理。
I feel like in general, as a dancer, if you're, like, trying to make it as a professional dancer in Los Angeles, you're coming across a lot of questionable opportunities. You're like, do I or don't I want to put on stilettos and a bikini and be in that music video, because I could totally do it, but-- so it felt a little bit like a Disney version of-- yeah, classy but, like, sexy classy. Sure.
我觉得总的来说，作为一个舞者，如果你试图在洛杉矶成为一名职业舞者，你会遇到很多可疑的机会。你会想，我到底要不要穿上细高跟鞋和比基尼出现在那个音乐录影带里，因为我完全做得到，但是——所以这感觉有点像迪士尼版本的——是的，优雅，但就像，性感优雅。当然。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
Yes. Sequins and hot pink all over your face. Whatever you want.
是的。满脸亮片和亮粉。随你怎么想。
Right. But don't sleep with any of the players.
对。但不要和任何球员上床。
But do not fornicate with the players, yeah.
但不要和球员通奸，是的。
It made sense to Robyn that they shouldn't sleep with the players. It made sense that Lisa told her what kind of push-up bra to wear and to get it specifically from Frederick's of Hollywood. It made sense that Lisa wanted her to be careful while dancing that she was doing her girl-next-door face and not a diva sex face.
Robyn觉得她们不应该和球员上床很有道理。Lisa告诉她穿什么样的聚拢文胸，并且必须具体在好莱坞的Frederick's买，这很有道理。Lisa想让她在跳舞时小心，保持邻家女孩的表情而不是那种诱惑的表情，这很有道理。
That all seemed reasonable. But Lisa had a lot of rules. They didn't all make sense.
这一切看起来都很合理。但Lisa有很多规则。并不是每一条都有道理。
One of the rules that we had was that we weren't allowed to drink water out of water bottles.
我们有的规则之一是我们不被允许从水瓶里喝水。
Why?
为什么？
This was like a rule. Every single rule came from Lisa. Totally, like, normal-but-a-little-intimidating Lisa would come to us and say, all right, no. OK, but no drinking water at these appearances. And then she explained that it was like because it was too provocative to drink out of a water bottle. Like, it just could connote something that would be--
这就像一条规则。每一条规则都来自Lisa。完全像，正常但有点令人生畏的Lisa会来到我们面前说，好吧，不。好的，但在这些活动中不准喝水。然后她解释说这是因为从水瓶里喝水太有挑逗性了。就像，它只会暗示一些会让——
What? What?
什么？什么？
I know.
我知道。
What's provocative about it?
它有什么挑逗性的？
Yeah, I don't know. I don't know. I don't think anyone was like, what do you mean? We were all just like, yeah, OK. Immediately, like, I'm trying to imagine what she's imagining. And it just suddenly seems like a everything gets slow motion and we're like, drinking water in this way that is just inappropriate. It's like suddenly, like, rated R water drinking.
是啊，我不知道。我不知道。我觉得当时没人会想，你是什么意思？我们都只是说，是的，好的。我立刻试图想象她在想象什么。突然间感觉一切都变慢动作了，我们就像在用一种不恰当的方式喝水。这就像突然间变成了限制级的喝水。
The word Robyn remembers Lisa using was "porny."
Robyn记得Lisa用的词是“色情”。
Yeah, it's porny. Yeah. Or at least to Lisa it is, or someone in the greater organization at one of her many afternoon meetings has told her, like, whoa, slow down on all the water drinking. Let's keep it wholesome. I don't know. I don't know.
是的，就是色情。是的。或者至少对Lisa来说是这样，或者在她的某次下午会议中，组织里的某个人告诉她，哇，少喝点水。我们保持健康一点。我不知道。我不知道。
If there is a line between classy and porny, cheerleading more than any other job I can think of is pushing right up against that line. It is dancing with pom-poms all over the line.
如果优雅和色情之间有一条界限，啦啦队是我能想到的比任何其他工作都更贴近那条界限的。这就是在那条线上挥舞着绒球跳舞。
So Robyn says the rules were there to keep things from accidentally crossing over. They're there to provide context. This thing we are doing is professional and classy. So even when Lisa's rules seemed a little crazy, Robyn went with it.
所以Robyn说规则的存在是为了防止意外越界。它们在那里是为了提供背景。我们所做的这件事是专业且优雅的。所以即使当Lisa的规则看起来有点疯狂时，Robyn也照做了。
She was trying to keep us safe-- appropriate and protected.
她在试图保护我们——得体且受保护。
Dd you feel that? Did you appreciate, like, she's looking out for us.
你感觉到了吗？你感激吗，比如，她在照顾我们。
Yeah, for sure. Yeah. She was kind of feminist protective of us. Everything that could have been, like, severely oversexed or really kind of disgusting, there was some kind of safety in place.
是的，当然。是的。她对我们有种女权主义式的保护。任何可能变成极端过度性感或真的令人作呕的事情，都有某种保护措施。
And that was Lisa.
那就是Lisa。
Oh, and that was Lisa. Yeah.
哦，那就是Lisa。是啊。
Oh my God, how are you?
天哪，你怎么样？
Fine. How are you?
还好。你怎么样？
I'm great, thanks.
我很好，谢谢。
Good. I know, I saw--
很好。我知道，我看到——
20 years after she left the team, Robyn called her old coach to say, I'm talking about you on the radio as my protector. Do you think about yourself that way?
她离开球队20年后，Robyn给她的老教练打电话说，我在广播里提到你是我作为保护者。你认为自己是那样的人吗？
Yeah, I mean, if people need to say that I'm, you know, mama hen, or I act like a mom, then I'm totally fine with that. And I think that I should be here to protect them.
是的，我的意思是，如果人们需要说我是个“老母鸡”，或者我的行为像个妈妈，那我完全没问题。而且我认为我应该在这里保护她们。
Sometimes it's a bit hard coming into a sports world with them. Sports world is a man's world, kind of. And there's definitely the stigma of they're just eye candy. And they go out, and they shake their pom-poms. Or they go out, and they dance, or whatever it is.
有时带着她们进入体育界有点困难。体育界是男人的世界，某种程度上。而且绝对有“她们只是花瓶”的污名。她们出去，她们摇动绒球。或者她们出去，她们跳舞，或者不管是什么。
But I wanted everyone in Los Angeles to understand they're not only dancing girls, they are so much more than that. And they should be looked at as professional women.
但我希望洛杉矶的每个人都明白，她们不仅仅是舞蹈女孩，她们远不止于此。她们应该被视为职业女性。
Lisa says she doesn't remember calling water bottles porny. But she's sure if she did, it was only because she wanted the women to be seen as professional. And Robyn says it worked. Yes, having a rule to tell you how often to change your tampon is ridiculous. But taken as a group, these rules made the whole thing into a job. They did make everything feel professional.
Lisa说她不记得把水瓶称为色情。但她肯定如果她这么说了，那只是因为她想让这些女性被视为专业人士。Robyn说这很有效。是的，有关于多久换一次卫生棉条的规则是荒谬的。但作为一个整体来看，这些规则把整件事变成了一份工作。它们确实让一切感觉很专业。
There is something wholesome about going to an NBA basketball game. There's families and kids. And it's bright. And it's familiar. And yes, and we were like the dance team that was wearing the logo that was printed on the outside of this massive stadium.
去现场看一场NBA篮球比赛有一种健康的感觉。有家庭和孩子。它是明亮的，是熟悉的。是的，我们就像是印在这个巨大体育场外面的带有标志的舞蹈队。
It just felt like, OK, we're all in it. Like we all kind of know what it is. And maybe we're like the sexualized talent entertainment component to all this, but it feels very rated G.
这只是感觉，好的，我们都在其中。就像我们都知道它是什么。也许我们就像所有这一切中性化的娱乐部分，但这感觉非常像G级（全年龄）。
It felt like that almost all the time. Almost.
几乎所有时间都感觉是那样。几乎。
The job was complicated at times. Like you'd see little-- you'd see it at the games sometimes. Like, you would be with Lakers fans who were just grown men with, like, their young sons, who would say, like, will you pose with my son? And you're like, yeah, sure.
这份工作有时很复杂。就像你有时会在比赛中看到一点点——比如，你会和那些带着年幼儿子的成年男性湖人球迷在一起，他们会说，你愿意和我儿子摆姿势吗？你会说，是的，当然。
And then you'd, like, get in a little huddle for the picture. And then the guy would say, OK, say sexy. And you're like, uh, that seems inappropriate.
然后你就像聚在一起拍照。然后那家伙会说，好的，说性感。你就会说，呃，那看起来不恰当。
The guy would say that to his kid, would say--
那家伙会对他的孩子那样说，会说——
He would just say it to us like that. And you're like, why don't you just say "say cheese"? And then you kind of remember. You're like, but actually, I'm standing here, like, in my push-up bra, like, wearing clothes close to what I would wear on the beach in a stadium with tons of other people wearing a lot more clothes than I am. Like, you'd have these moments of being like, oh.
他只是那样对我们说。你会想，为什么你不说“说茄子”呢？然后你就会记得。你会想，但实际上，我站在那儿，穿着聚拢文胸，穿着和我在海滩上差不多的衣服，在一个有成千上万穿得比我多得多的观众的体育场里。你会有这种感觉的瞬间：哦。
And there was the time they did the event at a bar called Pinky's. It was a pool hall where all the tables were covered in pink felt. The Laker Girls did their routines, but it was late and the men were drunk.
还有那次她们在一家叫Pinky's的酒吧参加活动。那是一个台球厅，所有的桌子都铺着粉红色的绒布。湖人女孩跳了她们的例行舞蹈，但时间很晚，男人们喝醉了。
Suddenly, you're, like, doing dance routines in like a smoky pool hall packed with kind of screaming men. And I feel like I had a-- like, something switched for me. Like, I saw what I was doing in a different way. It was just like one of those times where I thought, this feels like stripping right now.
突然，你在那种烟雾缭绕的台球厅里跳舞，周围挤满了尖叫的男人。我觉得我有种感觉——就像对我来说有什么东西切换了。就像我以一种不同的方式看待我所做的事情。那只是那种我以为这感觉就像脱衣舞的时候之一。
But then the event at Pinky's was over. And Robyn says those awkward moments usually faded quickly, because she loved the job. She loved what she was doing. And that, I guess, is what was still confusing to me.
但Pinky's的活动结束后。Robyn说那些尴尬的时刻通常很快就消失了，因为她热爱这份工作。她热爱她所做的一切。我想，这就是我仍然感到困惑的地方。
What is to love? You've got a coach who's up in your business, all of your business. You don't make a lot of money-- although in Robyn's case, the NBA pays a lot better than the NFL. But still, it's not player money.
有什么可爱的？你有一个干涉你私事的老板，干涉你所有的私事。你赚不到很多钱——尽管在Robyn的情况下，NBA的薪水比NFL好得多。但仍然，那不是球员的钱。
You can't gain three pounds. You can't even talk to the attractive famous young men right next to you. You can't drink bottled water. The more I learned, the more cheerleading sounds like walking through airport security over and over every day, just the feeling of being heavily policed with a bunch of unexplained arbitrary rules that are maybe there to keep you safe, but you don't really get why.
你不能胖三磅。你甚至不能和你旁边有吸引力的著名年轻男性说话。你不能喝瓶装水。我了解得越多，啦啦队听起来就越像每天一遍又一遍地通过机场安检，那种被严密监管的感觉，带着一堆无法解释的任意规则，也许它们是为了保证你的安全，但你真的不知道为什么。
And just, isn't it supposed to be fun? Is it fun? Robyn looks at me kind of pityingly when I ask about this.
而且，这难道不应该很有趣吗？它有趣吗？当我问这个问题时，Robyn带着同情的眼光看着我。
Is it fun?
它有趣吗？
I don't know that I can compare anything to being on stage in front of-- like, in a stadium under those lights in front of, like, 25,000 screaming fans. Even when I think about it now, it doesn't exactly feel like me. It's a little out-of-body.
我不知道我能把任何事情和站在25,000名尖叫粉丝面前的体育场舞台灯光下相比。即使我现在想到它，它也不太像我。有点出窍的感觉。
In like an awesome way?
以一种棒极了的方式？
In an amazing way, yeah. In an amazing way.
以一种惊人的方式，是的。以一种惊人的方式。
Robyn was part of the most elite professional level of cheerleading. She was dancing with people who were auditioning to go on tour with Madonna. It was Los Angeles. There were celebrities everywhere. Thousands of people came to games. She got to sit courtside next to Denzel Washington.
Robyn是啦啦队中最精英职业水平的一部分。她和那些试镜去麦当娜巡演的人一起跳舞。那是洛杉矶。到处都是名人。成千上万的人来看比赛。她可以坐在场边Denzel Washington旁边。
In other words, yes, moron, it was fun. It was really fun. In those moments, the rules and Lisa were not on her mind.
换句话说，是的，笨蛋，这很有趣。真的很有趣。在那些时刻，规则和Lisa根本不在她的脑海里。
Chana Joffe-Walt is one of the producers of our program. Coming up, the LA County Sheriff's Department loses an inmate in its own jail system on purpose. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
Chana Joffe-Walt是我们节目的制片人之一。接下来，洛杉矶县治安官部门故意在其监狱系统中丢失了一名囚犯。从芝加哥公共电台继续我们的节目，一分钟后回来。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Mind Your Own Business, AKA mind your own beeswax, AKA butt out, buzz off, MYOB. This is an A and B conversation, so C, your way out.
这是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。每周节目，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，带给您关于该主题的不同故事。今天的节目，《管好你自己的事》，又名“管好你自己的蜡，”又名“别管闲事”、“走开”。这是一个A和B的对话，所以C，请走开。
Why do you look at the speck in your brother's eye when you do not notice the plank in your own? Don't be dipping in the Kool-Aid when you don't even know the flavor. And a favorite in my family, people in glass houses shouldn't throw stones.
为什么当你没有注意到自己眼里的梁木时，却要看你兄弟眼里的刺呢？别在他人的事里插手，当你甚至不知道其中的味道时。我家人的最爱是：住在玻璃房子里的人不应该扔石头。
We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, Cop Versus Cop.
我们进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，警察对决警察。
Well, there's been a big, messy, fascinating story unfolding in Los Angeles for a while involving two big law enforcement agencies, the LA County Sheriff's Department, which is huge, and the FBI. A secret investigation got exposed. There were accusations and counter-accusations, clandestine recordings. And by the end, a bunch of people's careers were over.
嗯，在洛杉矶发生了一个大而混乱、引人入胜的故事，涉及两个大型执法机构，洛杉矶县治安官部门（规模巨大）和FBI。一个秘密调查被曝光。有指控和反指控，秘密录音。最后，许多人的职业生涯结束了。
At the heart of it was this-- nobody likes to be watched and reported on, judged by some outsider. No person likes it, and no organization likes it. Nancy Updike has the story.
核心在于这个——没有人喜欢被监视和举报，被某个外人评判。没有人喜欢，也没有组织喜欢。Nancy Updike报道了这个故事。
Employee Christmas parties are so often associated with bad behavior and just unwise choices that I believe they rival wedding toasts. About three years ago, Robert Faturechi, a reporter for the LA Times , heard about a Christmas party thrown by the Los Angeles County Sheriff's Department.
员工圣诞派对通常与不良行为和不明智的选择联系在一起，以至于我相信它们可以与婚礼祝酒词相媲美。大约三年前，《洛杉矶时报》的记者Robert Faturechi听说洛杉矶县治安官部门举办了一场圣诞派对。
At this beautiful banquet hall, there had been a massive fight between deputies.
在这个美丽的宴会厅里，副警长之间发生了一场大规模的斗殴。
This fight was not an argument. It was a fistfight among sheriff's deputies. And in Los Angeles County, sheriff's deputies are guards in the county jails, which does not mean that they're watching a few drunks sleep it off in a holding cell. This is the largest jail system in the country-- over 19,000 inmates at the moment.
这场斗殴不是争论。这是副警长之间的拳头斗殴。而在洛杉矶县，副警长是县监狱的守卫，这并不意味着他们是在监视几个醉汉在拘留室里睡觉。这是全国最大的监狱系统——目前有超过19,000名囚犯。
So Robert heard about the deputies' brawl at the Christmas party. And he started looking into what had happened. What he heard was that one group of deputies had beat up two other deputies. And the deputies who delivered the beating all worked on the same floor in the Sheriff Department's main jail.
所以Robert听说了副警长在圣诞派对上的打架事件。他开始调查发生了什么。他听说一群副警长殴打了另外两名副警长。而那些动手殴打的副警长都在治安官部门主要监狱的同一层工作。
It's called the 3000 floor. And I heard word that before the fight broke out, when they were exchanging words, these guys were throwing three-finger hand signs, similar to gang signs. There were rumors that they described themselves as the 3000 boys.
它被称为3000层。我听说在打架爆发前，当他们交换言语时，这些人正在比划三指手势，类似于帮派手势。有传言说他们称自己为“3000男孩”。
Mhm.
嗯。
So they were representing affiliation to a specific geographical area, the third floor of their jail. So in a lot of ways, they were like a gang.
所以他们是在代表与特定地理区域的从属关系，监狱的三楼。所以在很多方面，他们就像一个帮派。
Robert wondered, if they're beating up their fellow deputies, how are they treating inmates? This turned out to be a very good question, and also just the beginning. Because the first thing Robert found out was yes, most likely, some of the deputies who beat up other deputies were using extraordinary amounts of force on inmates. But it wasn't just the guys at the Christmas party.
Robert想知道，如果他们殴打自己的同事，他们是如何对待囚犯的？事实证明这是一个非常好的问题，也仅仅是个开始。因为Robert发现的第一件事是，是的，很可能，一些殴打同事的副警长在囚犯身上使用了超常规的武力。但这不仅仅是圣诞派对上的那些家伙。
Robert dug into public records about use of force reports in the jail, and later, internal Sheriff's Department documents-- these had never been made public-- that showed that the department knew that brutality against inmates was a real problem in the jails, that deputies were beating inmates, fabricating stories to justify beatings, that investigations after the fact were shoddy. Robert was also hearing more and more from sources inside the Sheriff's Department. He published a series of stories with headlines like, "LA County Deputy Says He Was Forced to Beat Mentally Ill Inmate" and "Monitor Says She Saw Deputies Beat Inmate, quote, 'Like a Punching Bag.'"
Robert深入挖掘了关于监狱使用武力报告的公共记录，以及后来——从未公开过的——内部治安官部门文件，这些文件显示，部门知道针对囚犯的暴行是监狱里的一个真正问题，副警长正在殴打囚犯，编造故事来为殴打辩护，事后的调查也是敷衍了事。Robert还从治安官部门内部的线人那里听到了越来越多的消息。他发表了一系列文章，标题如《洛杉矶县副警长称他被迫殴打精神病囚犯》和《监督员称她看到副警长殴打囚犯，“就像打沙袋一样”。》
Robert talked to a former commander who said there were deputies who really did seem to have formed their own gangs in the jail.
Robert采访了一位前指挥官，他说确实有副警长在监狱里形成了自己的帮派。
I mean, this was a high-ranking guy. He told us that deputies were literally breaking inmates' bones. In order to get membership into these gang-like groups of deputies, they had to break inmates' bones. And, I mean, that's the kind of thing that if I had heard before all of this started to unfold, I would never believe it.
我的意思是，这是一个高级别的人。他告诉我们副警长确实在折断囚犯的骨头。为了获得这些副警长帮派组织的成员资格，他们必须折断囚犯的骨头。而且，我的意思是，如果我在这一切开始展开之前听说过这种事，我永远不会相信。
But this was a department commander telling us this. I mean, this guy was in charge of hundreds of deputies. He's someone who came up through the system who has a lot of loyalty to the system.
但这是一位部门指挥官告诉我们的。我的意思是，这家伙负责数百名副警长。他是通过系统晋升起来的，对系统有很强的忠诚度。
At the same time that Robert was digging all of this up, another organization was also looking into the jails-- not a news organization, the FBI.
在Robert挖掘这一切的同时，另一个组织也在调查监狱——不是新闻机构，是FBI。
The date is August 30, 2010 at 9:45 AM. This is Special Agent Leah Marx. I will soon begin a consensual recording with target William David Courson, Junior at Lazy Daisy Cafe in Los Angeles.
日期是2010年8月30日上午9:45。这是特别探员Leah Marx。我即将开始对目标William David Courson Junior进行秘密录音，地点是洛杉矶的Lazy Daisy咖啡馆。
Leah Marx was the lead FBI investigator looking into inmate abuse at the LA jails. Just to clarify, when she says "consensual recording," that's FBI speak. It means she's consenting. The other guy doesn't know she's recording.
Leah Marx是调查洛杉矶监狱囚犯虐待案的首席FBI调查员。澄清一下，当她说“秘密录音”时，那是FBI的行话。意思是她是知情的。对方不知道她在录音。
Marx had been going out to the main jail in downtown LA for a while, investigating corruption and brutality by deputies against inmates. But the Sheriff's Department had no idea that's what she was looking into. FBI agents go to jails all the time to meet with informants. Agent Marx told one deputy at the jail she was working on a human trafficking case.
Marx已经去洛杉矶市中心的监狱有一段时间了，调查副警长对囚犯的腐败和暴行。但治安官部门根本不知道她在调查什么。FBI探员经常去监狱与线人会面。Marx探员告诉监狱的一名副警长，她正在处理一起人口贩运案件。
This particular recording at the Lazy Daisy Cafe came about because one of the deputies, Deputy William Courson, asked Agent Marx out. He had a crush on her She turned him down. But later she talked with her supervisor, and they decided that Deputy Courson could be a good source of intel. Marx told Courson she would go out with him, but just as friends. No dating. She wasn't interested.
Lazy Daisy咖啡馆的这次特定录音是因为其中一名副警长，Deputy William Courson，约Marx探员出去。他暗恋她。她拒绝了他。但后来她和主管谈过，他们决定副警长Courson可能是一个很好的情报来源。Marx告诉Courson她会和他出去，但只是作为朋友。不约会。她对他不感兴趣。
So they go out to breakfast. She has French toast. He has eggs. And she's asking him about his job. And he's telling her about violence in the jail, inmates beating up other inmates. Courson says in some cases, "They're going to get beat down by their own people, more than likely worse than what we would normally do to them. Which is bad, because we send them to the hospital."
所以他们去吃早餐。她吃了法式吐司。他吃了鸡蛋。她正在问他关于工作的事。他正在告诉她监狱里的暴力事件，囚犯殴打其他囚犯。Courson说在某些情况下，“他们会被自己人打得很惨，很可能比我们平时对待他们的还要严重。这很糟糕，因为我们得把他们送到医院。”
They're going to get beat down by their own people, more than likely worse than what we would normally do to them. Which is bad, because we send them to the hospital.
他们会被自己人打得很惨，很可能比我们平时对待他们的还要严重。这很糟糕，因为我们得把他们送到医院。
Like, why though?
但是，为什么呢？
Why what?
为什么什么？
Why would you guys send them to the hospital?
为什么你们要把他们送到医院？
Because every time they fight with us, it's like an unwritten rule. They go to the hospital.
因为每次他们和我们打架，这就像一条不成文的规定。他们得去医院。
He's saying, "Every time they fight with us, it's like an unwritten rule. They go to the hospital." He says, "Sometimes, they don't even have to make the first move. If we just perceive that they want to fight, we don't have to wait for them to hit us."
他说，“每次他们和我们打架，这就像一条不成文的规定。他们得去医院。”他说，“有时，他们甚至不必先动手。如果我们只是感觉到他们想打架，我们不必等到他们打我们。”
Marx keeps asking, but is this how you're trained officially by the Sheriff's Department, that you're legally allowed to beat someone to the point that they go to the hospital if you even think they might do something? Courson says that it all depends on how the deputies write up the incident in their report.
Marx一直在问，但这是治安官部门正式训练你们的方式吗，即如果你甚至认为他们可能会做什么，你就被法律允许殴打某人到他们去医院的程度？Courson说这完全取决于副警长如何在报告中撰写事件。
As long as they don't quit fighting, that's the way you write it.
只要他们不停手，你就是那样写的。
[LAUGHS] Got it.
[笑声] 明白了。
They go back and forth like this, law enforcement officer to law enforcement officer talking shop. Courson says they've got new rules for how long to taser someone. "What they want you to do now is hold the taser, hold the trigger, until you actually get them handcuffed."
他们像这样来回交谈，执法人员对执法人员谈论工作。Courson说他们有了关于电击某人多长时间的新规则。“他们现在想要你做的是拿着电击枪，扣住扳机，直到你真正把他们拷上。”
So what they want you to do now is hold the taser, hold the trigger, until you actually get them handcuffed.
所以他们现在想要你做的是拿着电击枪，扣住扳机，直到你真正把他们拷上。
That can be  a long time.
那可能会是很长一段时间。
"That can be a long time," says Marx. Courson says, "Oh yeah. Depends on how clumsy we are."
“那可能会是很长一段时间，”Marx说。Courson说，“哦，是的。取决于我们有多笨手笨脚。”
Oh, yeah. Depends on how clumsy we are. [LAUGHS] Ah, I didn't even think about it before I saw them. But tomato? Would you like a tomato?
哦，是的。取决于我们有多笨手笨脚。[笑声] 啊，在我看到它们之前我甚至没想过。但是西红柿？你想要个西红柿吗？
No. No, thanks. Tomatoes and French toast, not exactly a--
不。不，谢谢。西红柿和法式吐司，不太像一个——
No, probably not. But I like tomatoes.
不，可能不是。但我喜欢西红柿。
Interesting. So, like, how do you guys get to the point, where, like you learn all the unwritten rules?
有趣。那么，你们是怎么学到所有那些不成文的规则的？
She says, "So how do you guys get to the point where you learn all the unwritten rules?" "About sending them to the hospital?" Courson says. "I think think just like in general," Marx says.
她说，“那么你们是怎么学到所有那些不成文的规则的？”“关于送他们去医院？”Courson说。“我想只是普遍来说，”Marx说。
Like for us--
比如对我们——
About sending them to the hospital?
关于送他们去医院？
I think just like in general, because--
我想只是普遍来说，因为——
They tell us.
他们告诉我们。
"They tell us," he says. He explains that he learned the unwritten rules while he was still at the Academy, just after graduating, during a training called jail ops-- jail operations. He says "After we graduate, you go through I think it's a week or two-week course of jail ops. During that time, that's when they tell you it's an unwritten rule that any inmate that fights with deputies goes to the hospital."
“他们告诉我们，”他说。他解释说他在还在学院时就学到了那些不成文的规定，就在毕业后，在一次叫做“监狱行动”的培训中。他说：“毕业后，你会经历我想是一两周的监狱行动课程。在那段时间，那是他们告诉你，任何与副警长打架的囚犯都要去医院是不成文的规定。”
During that time, that's when they tell you it's an unwritten rule that any inmate that fights with deputies goes to the hospital.
在那段时间，那是他们告诉你，任何与副警长打架的囚犯都要去医院是不成文的规定。
Got it. Even if it's not necessary, you do it. You just teach  them a lesson, or what?
明白了。即使没必要，你也会做。你只是给他们一个教训，还是什么？
Pretty much.
差不多吧。
Marx says, "Got it. Even if it's not necessary, you do it. You just teach them a lesson. Courson says, "Pretty much." Courson said later that he doesn't like some of what he sees going on at the jail. He says about the inmates, "Some of them I like. From what I know of them, they're decent people. But kind of like what we said before, the only thing that's separating me and them is one mistake."
Marx说，“明白了。即使没必要，你也会做。你只是给他们一个教训。”Courson说，“差不多吧。”Courson后来表示他不喜欢他在监狱里看到的一些事。他说关于囚犯，“有些我喜欢。据我所知，他们是正派的人。但有点像我们之前说的，唯一把我与他们分开的是一个错误。”
Robert, the LA Times guy who reported on the Christmas party fight, eventually heard about the FBI's investigation into the jails-- not from the FBI, but as a series of rumors going around.
Robert，那位报道圣诞派对打架事件的洛杉矶时报记者，最终听说了FBI对监狱的调查——不是来自FBI，而是作为传闻在流传。
We started to hear that the FBI had smuggled a cell phone to an inmate who was secretly acting as an informant.
我们开始听说FBI给了一名秘密担任线人的囚犯一部手机。
This was the informant working with FBI agent Leah Marx, telling her about abuse in the jail. The phone was so that the informant could try and take pictures or video to back up inmates' stories about brutality and corruption by some of the deputies. But there was a problem with this plan, which is cell phones are illegal in jail. And pretty quickly, deputies found the informant's cellphone during a routine search.
这就是与FBI探员Leah Marx合作的线人，告诉她监狱里的虐待事件。手机是为了让线人尝试拍摄照片或视频，以支持囚犯关于某些副警长的暴行和腐败的故事。但这个计划有一个问题，那就是手机在监狱里是非法的。很快，副警长在一次例行检查中发现了线人的手机。
LA Times headline, "FBI Paid Deputy to Smuggle Cell Phone in Jail Sting." Deputies found the phone wrapped in a glove and hidden inside a potato chip bag. And wow, was the Sheriff's Department mad that the FBI had done this. The sheriffs and the FBI were used to being more or less on the same side. Here's Robert.
《洛杉矶时报》标题，“FBI付钱给副警长走私手机进入监狱”。副警长们发现手机被包裹在手套里，藏在薯片袋里。哇，治安官部门对FBI这样做感到非常愤怒。治安官和FBI习惯于或多或少站在同一边。这是Robert。
They work with each other on a ton of task forces.
他们在大量的特别工作组里互相合作。
Right.
对。
They have a close relationship. And this is the kind of thing that would be seen as a huge betrayal.
他们有亲密的关系。而这会被视为巨大的背叛。
All right. Here comes the Sheriff. He's right here. Sheriff Lee Baca is with us.
好了。治安官来了。他就在这儿。治安官Lee Baca和我们在一起。
He just called you Sheriff Steve.
他刚才叫你治安官Steve。
You're here to talk about something near-and-dear that you're involved in.
你是来谈论一件你参与其中的切身相关的事情。
This is the morning show on the local Fox TV affiliate in LA. Sheriff Lee Baca, who is in charge of the entire LA County Sheriff's Department, is sitting there with the hosts. This is right after Robert's first story in the LA Times about the smuggled cellphone.
这是洛杉矶当地福克斯电视台的早间节目。负责整个洛杉矶县治安官部门的治安官Lee Baca正和主持人们坐在一起。这就在Robert在《洛杉矶时报》关于走私手机的第一篇报道之后。
Baca's tone is measured as he answers the interviewer's questions, but it's clear he's really angry.
Baca在回答采访者的问题时语气沉稳，但很明显他真的很生气。
And I think it's a--
我认为这是——
Do you resent the FBI's intrusion?
你反感FBI的闯入吗？
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
And specifically, this issue about a cell phone.
特别是关于手机的问题。
Right.
对。
What can you tell us about that?
你能告诉我们关于那件事吗？
Well, it's illegal. It's a misdemeanor. And then there's a conspiracy law that goes along with it. The truth is, the sheriff runs the jail. And the sheriff's responsibilities have to be respected.
嗯，这是非法的。这是一个轻罪。然后有一个随之而来的共谋法。事实是，治安官管理监狱。治安官的责任必须得到尊重。
The sheriff was publicly saying, you know, the Feds have committed a crime. We police ourselves. Mind your own business. We've got this.
治安官公开说，你知道，联邦政府犯罪了。我们自己管自己。管好你自己的事。我们能搞定。
And the Feds, they were absolutely infuriated that the Sheriff of LA County was publicly accusing them of a crime.
而联邦政府，他们对洛杉矶县治安官公开指控他们犯罪感到非常愤怒。
Of course, the FBI did do something illegal. Not only did they give their informant a cell phone in jail, but they also bribed a corrupt deputy with $1,500 to smuggle in that phone. But the FBI is not regular people. Different rules apply to them.
当然，FBI确实做了一些违法的事。他们不仅给了他们的线人在监狱里一部手机，而且还贿赂了一名腐败的副警长1500美元来走私那部手机。但FBI不是普通人。不同的规则适用于他们。
The smuggled phone, although illegal, was part of an authorized FBI investigation into other illegal activity-- abuse by deputies. And that's exactly the kind of trade off that the FBI is allowed to make in some situations. They're legally permitted to let their informants commit certain crimes, though never a violent crime.
走私的手机，虽然非法，是一项被授权的FBI对其他非法活动——副警长滥用职权——调查的一部分。而这正是FBI在某些情况下被允许做出的权衡。他们被法律允许让他们的线人犯某些罪，但绝不是暴力犯罪。
But the Sheriff's Department was not backing down. On the contrary, they counter-punched, saying to the FBI essentially, you're coming after us? We're coming after you.
但治安官部门没有退缩。相反，他们反击，基本上对FBI说，你们要追究我们？我们要追究你们。
Testing. Do you have a tape rolling?
测试。你有录音带在转吗？
On the same day that Sheriff Lee Baca went on TV, the Sheriff's Department sent two of its sergeants to FBI agent Leah Marx's home. They recorded the whole encounter. They waited outside her apartment. And one of the Sheriff's officials, Sergeant Scott Craig, spots FBI agent Leah Marx and calls out to her.
就在治安官Lee Baca上电视的那天，治安官部门派遣了两名中士到FBI探员Leah Marx的家。他们录下了整个相遇过程。他们在她的公寓外等待。其中一名治安官官员，Scott Craig中士，发现了FBI探员Leah Marx并喊她。
Hi, Leah Marx? Leah?
嗨，Leah Marx？Leah？
Yeah?
是？
Hi, I'm Sergeant Craig from the Sheriff's Department. I left you a message a couple weeks ago. We're here to talk to you--
嗨，我是治安官部门的Craig中士。我几周前给你留了言。我们是来和你谈谈的——
I don't have anything to say.
我没什么可说的。
OK, so you don't wan to talk to us?
好的，所以你不想和我们谈谈？
No, thanks.
不，谢谢。
Do you want my card or anything?
你想要我的卡片或其他什么吗？
Yes, I would, please, actually.
是的，我想要，事实上。
You know that you're a named suspect in a felony complaint?
你知道你是重罪起诉书中的指定嫌疑人吗？
It's hard to hear this part, but Sergeant Craig is saying, "Do you know that you're a named suspect in a felony complaint?" In other words, they showed up at her home not to say, "We're arresting you," but to say, "We might be about to arrest you." No matter what FBI Agent Marx says, Sergeant Craig keeps telling her, "We might be about to arrest you."
很难听清这一部分，但Craig中士说，“你知道你是重罪起诉书中的指定嫌疑人吗？”换句话说，他们出现在她家不是为了说，“我们要逮捕你”，而是说，“我们可能要逮捕你了”。无论FBI探员Marx说什么，Craig中士一直告诉她，“我们可能要逮捕你了”。
OK. What I'm going to do, so you know, is I'm in the process of swearing out a declaration for an arrest warrant for you. Would you like us to go through who?
好的。我要做的是，让你知道，我正在为你的逮捕令签署声明。你想让我们通过谁？
I would prefer that you would actually contact the officials who are in charge of the FBI.
我希望你们能联系负责FBI的官员。
OK. Well, what we're going to do to arrange for your arrest when we're ready to do that is we can either do this--
好的。嗯，我们要做的就是当我们准备好安排你的逮捕时，我们可以这样做——
No, I would-- you need to contact the FBI office.
不，我想要——你需要联系FBI办公室。
They basically say that they're going to issue a warrant for her arrest, and that they're investigating her for the crime of smuggling a cell phone into the jail. And she basically says, talk to my boss. And then we have a recording of this. Her boss calls these sheriff's investigators.
他们基本上说他们要发出她的逮捕令，并且他们正在调查她向监狱走私手机的罪行。而她基本上说，联系我的老板。然后我们有这个录音。她的老板打电话给这些治安官调查员。
OK, go ahead.
好的，继续。
This is Sergeant Maricela Long from the Sheriff's Department. She had been with Sergeant Craig outside FBI Agent Leah Marx's house. Sergeant Long recorded this call with the FBI.
这是来自治安官部门的Maricela Long中士。她一直和Craig中士在FBI探员Leah Marx家外面。Long中士录下了这个与FBI的通话。
So you're with who, sir?
那么你是和谁在一起，先生？
She indicated to me that you guys indicated to there being a warrant for her arrest?
她向我表示你们暗示有她的逮捕令？
There's going to be.
会有逮捕令的。
Does the sheriff know this?
治安官知道这件事吗？
The sheriff knows this, sir.
治安官知道这件事，先生。
OK. Can I ask what the charges are going to be?
好的。我可以问会有什么指控吗？
OK. You're going to have to speak to the undersheriff.
好的。你得去和副治安官谈谈。
Sergeant Long gives the phone number for the undersheriff. And then they wrap up the call.
Long中士给了副治安官的电话号码。然后他们结束了通话。
You don't have any idea when the warrant's going to come out, do you?
你不知道逮捕令什么时候出来，是吗？
It could be tomorrow, sir. You're going to have to talk to the undersheriff.
可能是明天，先生。你得去和副治安官谈谈。
OK, thank you.
好的，谢谢。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
And at the end of the recording, you know, after they say goodbye to each other, they forget to stop recording, the sheriff's investigators do.
而在录音结束时，你知道，在他们告别之后，他们忘记停止录音了，治安官调查员们。
Oh, no.
哦，不。
And one of the investigators basically kind of jubilantly goes, "They're scared!"
其中一名调查员基本上兴高采烈地说，“他们吓坏了！”
They're scared! They're like, do you know when-- is the warrant--
他们吓坏了！他们就像，你知道什么时候——逮捕令是——
You're still rolling.
你还在录音。
And her colleague says, you're still rolling! And the tape ends. But it spoke to their frame of mind.
而她的同事说，你还在录音！然后录音带结束了。但这说明了他们的心态。
They're scared, meaning we scared the FBI. Like, yay.
他们吓坏了，意味着我们吓到了FBI。就像，耶。
Yeah. She sounded really pleased that the FBI had been spooked by them showing up at this agent's door.
是的。她听起来对FBI被他们出现在探员门口而吓到感到非常高兴。
So what started as an investigation into serious inmate abuse was now being overshadowed by an institutional-sized shoving match between the Feds and the LA Sheriff's Department. And the next big shove in that match was a pretty dramatic one-- the Feds accusing sheriff's officials of obstruction of justice, intentionally thwarting a federal investigation.
所以，最初调查严重囚犯虐待案的事件，现在被联邦调查局和洛杉矶治安官部门之间机构规模的推搡戏所掩盖了。在那场比赛中，下一次巨大的推搡是一个相当戏剧性的推搡——联邦政府指控治安官官员妨碍司法，蓄意阻挠联邦调查。
And you could argue that the Feds had the beginnings of a case. The sheriff's agents who went to see Marx-- the Feds could paint that as intimidation. The Sheriff's Department gloating at the end of the phone call with the FBI-- Feds could argue it showed intent.
你可以说联邦政府有了一个案件的开端。去见Marx的治安官特工——联邦政府可以将此描绘为恐吓。治安官部门在与FBI的电话通话结束时的幸灾乐祸——联邦政府可以辩称这显示了意图。
And then there was this-- remember the informant, the guy the FBI had smuggled the cellphone to? Almost as soon as his cover was blown, the Feds couldn't find him. They demanded that the Sheriff's Department let them meet with their informant. And the Sheriff's Department-- I'll let Robert, the LA Times reporter tell it.
然后还有这个——还记得那个线人，联邦调查局走私手机给他的人吗？几乎在他被暴露的瞬间，联邦政府就找不到他了。他们要求治安官部门让他们与他们的线人会面。而治安官部门——我让Robert，《洛杉矶时报》的记者来告诉你。
I mean, I started to get calls from sources. And they were telling me various versions of this tale, that the inmate who'd been secretly working as an informant for the FBI was being moved around the jails. And all of this was done in an effort to hide him from the FBI.
我的意思是，我开始接到线人的电话。他们告诉我这个故事的各种版本，那个一直秘密为FBI担任线人的囚犯正在监狱里被转来转去。而这一切都是为了把他从FBI那里藏起来。
Moved around. You mean you mean physically moved?
转来转去。你是说你是说身体上的移动？
Sure. Yeah, so what you've got to understand is that LA County and the LA County jail system is so massive. It's not just one jail downtown or two jails. There are jails downtown. Then there are jails spread across the county, you know, holding cells inside of stations.
当然。是的，所以你必须明白的是，洛杉矶县和洛杉矶县监狱系统是如此巨大。这不仅仅是一个市中心的监狱或两个监狱。市中心有监狱。然后有分布在全县的监狱，你知道，车站内的拘留室。
And so they were moving him from one floor to another, from one facility to another. And this is the largest jail system in the country. So there are dozens of places you could put an inmate if you don't want him to be found.
所以他们把他从一层移动到另一层，从一个设施移动到另一个设施。这是全国最大的监狱系统。所以如果你不想让他被发现，有几十个地方可以安放一个囚犯。
And my initial response to hearing such wild stories is skepticism. I mean, I just couldn't believe that you would literally hide a human being and ignore requests from the FBI. It seemed too unbelievable to me.
而我听到如此疯狂的故事时的最初反应是怀疑。我的意思是，我简直无法相信你会真的藏起一个人并忽略FBI的请求。这对我来说太不可思议了。
So Robert started asking around, trying to find this mystery informant. But it seemed like a lost cause. He didn't even know the guy's name.
所以Robert开始到处打听，试图找到这个神秘的线人。但这看起来像是毫无希望。他甚至不知道这家伙的名字。
So one Friday evening, I was leaving. And I'm on my way out, I checked my mail. I went to my mailbox, and I grabbed the letters that had come in. And at this point, we'd been writing about inmate abuse for a while. And I didn't know it before, but what happens when you write about inmate abuse and when you write about jails is you start getting letters from prisoners everywhere-- not just in LA County, across the state.
所以一个周五晚上，我正要离开。我正要出门，我检查了我的邮件。我走到我的邮箱，拿到了寄来的信。而在这一点上，我们已经写了一段时间关于囚犯虐待的文章。我之前不知道，但当你写关于囚犯虐待和写关于监狱的文章时，你会开始收到来自各地囚犯的来信——不仅仅是在洛杉矶县，在全州。
And they're all trying to tell you about their own experience, their own experience being abused, their own experience being wrongly convicted. And some of them are probably true. But again, what happens in jails is really hard to prove. And we are so busy that-- I'm not proud of this-- but I wouldn't always read these letters closely.
他们都试图告诉你他们自己的经历，他们自己被虐待的经历，他们自己被错误定罪的经历。其中一些可能是真实的。但同样，在监狱里发生的事情真的很难证明。而且我们太忙了——我对此并不自豪——但我不会总是仔细阅读这些信件。
And so one of these letters had come in. And I was sort of just reading it while walking out. And the guy was saying, I'm the FBI's informant.
所以其中一封信寄到了。我当时正走出去时顺便读了一下。那家伙说，我是FBI的线人。
Oh, my god.
哦，天哪。
I'm the guy who was at the center of all this.
我就是那个处于这一切中心的人。
So wait. You were looking for him, and as you were looking for him, you got a letter from him?
等等。你在找他，当你找他的时候，你收到了一封他的信？
Yeah. Well, honestly, at that point, I thought the chances of me finding him, I didn't think it would be possible. And then comes this letter. And he's describing exactly the rumor that I'd been hearing, that he had been moved around, that they had changed his name.
是的。嗯，说实话，在那一点上，我认为我找到他的机会，我不认为那是可能的。然后来了这封信。他正在描述我一直听到的确切谣言，他被转来转去，他们改了他的名字。
The guy's name was Anthony Brown. And he had been transferred to prison by this point, so he was out of the jail system. And Robert and his reporting partner Jack Leonard went down to see him.
那家伙的名字叫Anthony Brown。他那时已经被转移到监狱了，所以他不在监狱系统里了。Robert和他的报道伙伴Jack Leonard下去见他。
All I knew about him at that point was that he was this convicted bank robber facing-- I forget what his sentence was-- like 323 years in prison or something.
我那时对他所知道的一切就是他是一个被定罪的银行劫匪，面临——我忘了他的刑期是多少——就像323年的监禁之类的。
Yeah, yeah. Hundreds of years.
是啊，是啊。几百年。
And I was expecting this big, tough, scary-looking guy. And in walks Anthony Brown. And he's this, like, pudgy, sweet guy who's got, like, these glasses and this, like, really charming New York accent. When you're just thinking about what a bank robber looks like, you're not imagining Anthony Brown,
我期待着一个高大、强悍、看起来很吓人的家伙。然后Anthony Brown走了进来。他就像，这个胖乎乎、甜甜的家伙，戴着这些眼镜，带着这个，真的迷人的纽约口音。当你只是在想一个银行劫匪长什么样时，你想象不到Anthony Brown。
Anthony Brown told him a lot. He confirmed that yes, the cell phone had been smuggled in by a deputy who was bribed with $1,500. Yes, Anthony Brown was moved around the jails. He was hidden inside the jail system by deputies who guarded him 24 hours a day and rebooked him under aliases that would change every 48 hours.
Anthony Brown告诉了他很多。他证实是的，手机是由一名被贿赂1500美元的副警长走私进来的。是的，Anthony Brown在监狱里被转来转去。他被看守他24小时的副警长藏在监狱系统里，并以每48小时变动一次的别名重新登记。
Brown also told Robert and Jack that he had seen a lot of abuse of inmates by deputies. He said he'd kept notes. His description of daily life in the jail was in line with what Robert and Jack had already reported out through documents and sources.
Brown还告诉Robert和Jack，他看到了很多副警长对囚犯的虐待。他说他做了笔记。他对监狱日常生活的描述与Robert和Jack通过文件和线人已经报道出来的内容是一致的。
But Brown said a lot of other stuff that just did not seem to be true. He told Robert and Jack that he'd been a high-level executive at Def Jam Recordings. Def Jam said they'd never heard of him. He told Robert and Jack that he'd made a ton of money being on tour with Beyonce. Couldn't nail that down. And there were other things.
但Brown说了很多其他听起来并不真实的东西。他告诉Robert和Jack，他曾是Def Jam录音公司的高级主管。Def Jam说他们从未听说过他。他告诉Robert和Jack，他作为Beyonce巡演的一部分赚了很多钱。无法证实这一点。还有其他的事情。
So as a witness in a case about inmate abuse, if it was just Brown testifying about what he'd seen, no evidence to back up his claims, that would be a hard sell. But for an obstruction case, Brown told Robert and Jack one story that ended up being very important and that other people could corroborate.
所以作为一起关于囚犯虐待案的证人，如果只是Brown作证他看到了什么，没有证据支持他的说法，那将很难推销。但对于一个妨碍司法案件，Brown告诉Robert和Jack的一件事最终变得非常重要，并且其他人可以证实。
Immediately after his cover was blown, before they were able to really get the operation to move him and change his name, his FBI handler had gotten into the jail to interview him, because they had gotten word that this cover was blown. And they're in this room, and they're meeting and they're talking. And a couple sheriff's officials barge in and declare, this meeting is over. They kick him out. They kick the agent out.
他的掩护被暴露后，在他们真正能够进行行动把他转移并改名之前，他的FBI处理人进入了监狱去采访他，因为他们得到了那个掩护被暴露的消息。他们在一个房间里，他们正在见面，正在交谈。几个治安官官员闯入并宣布，这次会议结束了。他们把他踢出去。他们把探员踢出去。
And that was really interesting. It showed an explicit effort to get in the way of a conversation between an FBI agent and an informant. And that was one of the main arguments, that the Sheriff's Department tried to obstruct a federal investigation, which is a crime.
这真的很有趣。这显示了一个明确的努力去妨碍FBI探员和线人之间的谈话。这是主要论点之一，即治安官部门试图阻挠联邦调查，这是一种犯罪。
That incident? That incident was cited as a main piece of evidence.
那个事件？那个事件被引用为证据的主要部分。
Yeah. Yeah, that incident was cited. That was a federal interview, and they came in and they basically shut it down. And they kicked the agent out.
是的。是的，那个事件被引用了。那是一次联邦采访，他们闯进来，基本上终止了它。他们把探员踢出去。
The Sheriff's Department said yes, they had interrupted the FBI's meeting with Brown, but to protect him according to a newly heightened security protocol. In fact, they said none of what had happened was intentional obstruction of justice. They said they'd moved Anthony Brown around the jails and hidden him not to keep him away from the Feds, but to keep him safe from possible retribution by the deputies he was informing on.
治安官部门说是的，他们打断了FBI与Brown的会面，但这是根据一项新加强的安全协议来保护他。事实上，他们说所发生的一切都不是蓄意的妨碍司法。他们说他们把Anthony Brown在监狱里转来转去并藏起来不是为了让他远离联邦政府，而是为了让他免受他所举报的副警长可能的报复。
So far, jurors have not bought these arguments. Toward the end of 2013, the Feds brought obstruction of justice cases against seven people in the LA County Sheriff's Department. Six have been convicted, including the two sergeants who went to FBI Agent Leah Marx's home. One more case ended with a hung jury. It's going to be retried.
到目前为止，陪审员们并没有相信这些论点。在2013年底，联邦政府对洛杉矶县治安官部门的七个人提起了妨碍司法诉讼。六人被定罪，包括那两名去FBI探员Leah Marx家的中士。另一个案件以陪审团僵局结束。它将被重审。
But Robert, the LA Times reporter, said even before these convictions, even before anyone was charged in these obstruction cases, the Sheriff's Department was coming under more pressure than it ever had to deal with brutality against inmates by deputies. The FBI investigation came on top of a whole pile of complaints and evidence that had been building up for years, from civilian monitors of the police, from the ACLU, from media reports. Facing all that, the sheriff implemented reforms. And now, Robert says from everything he hears from people on the inside, though there's still problems in the jails, the inmates are treated differently.
但Robert，《洛杉矶时报》的记者说，甚至在这些定罪之前，甚至在妨碍司法案件中任何人被指控之前，治安官部门正受到比以往任何时候都更大的压力，去处理副警长针对囚犯的暴行。FBI的调查是在多年来积累的一整堆投诉和证据之上进行的，来自警察的民间监督员，来自美国公民自由联盟（ACLU），来自媒体报道。面对所有这些，治安官实施了改革。而现在，Robert说从他从内部人士那里听到的所有事情来看，尽管监狱里仍然存在问题，但囚犯的待遇有所不同。
A few months ago, Sheriff Lee Baca, who had headed the department for 15 years, resigned. One last fact to chew on-- the Sheriff's Department plan to hide Anthony Brown in the jail system was called Operation Pandora's Box. I didn't quite do a double take when I read that, but I did think it wasn't the best myth to choose. The story doesn't end well for anyone who's hoping to contain something or keep it hidden. Pandora opens the box, and the contents fly out for the whole world to see.
几个月前，领导该部门15年的治安官Lee Baca辞职了。最后一个值得思考的事实——治安官部门在监狱系统里藏匿Anthony Brown的计划被称为“潘多拉魔盒行动”。我读到那个时并没有感到惊讶，但我确实认为这不是选择的最佳神话。对于任何希望控制某些东西或保持其隐藏的人来说，这个故事的结果并不好。潘多拉打开了盒子，里面的东西飞出来让全世界都看到了。
Nancy Updike is one of the producers of our program. Robert Faturechi is a reporter at the Los Angeles Times who's covered law enforcement since 2010. We contacted the LA County Sheriff's Department about the recent history of violence against inmates in the jails. And they sent this statement.
Nancy Updike是我们节目的制片人之一。Robert Faturechi是《洛杉矶时报》的记者，自2010年以来一直报道执法工作。我们就监狱中针对囚犯的暴力行为的近期历史联系了洛杉矶县治安官部门。他们发来了这份声明。
Quote, "Over the past few years, the department has made a multitude of changes which have transformed the custody environment. Some of these changes include innovative ideas which have not previously been implemented in large jail systems. Use of force incidents have dropped significantly in comparison to 2011 and earlier."
引用，“在过去几年里，该部门进行了大量的改革，改变了羁押环境。其中一些改革包括在大型监狱系统中以前从未实施过的创新想法。与2011年及以前相比，使用武力事件显著下降。”
Well, our program was produced today by Miki Meek with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Alison Davis and JP Dukes. It is Alison's last program with us here as our visiting fellow, and we all wish her the best.
嗯，我们的节目今天由Miki Meek制作，Alex Blumberg，Ben Calhoun，Sean Cole，Stephanie Foo，Chana Joffe-Walt，Sarah Koenig，Jonathan Menjivar，Brian Reed，Robyn Semien，Alissa Shipp和Nancy Updike参与。我们的资深制片人是Julie Snyder。制作帮助来自Alison Davis和JP Dukes。这是Alison作为我们访问学者在我们这里的最后一个节目，我们祝她一切顺利。
Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon is our production manager. Elise Begerson's our administrative assistant. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Research help from Michelle Harris and Julie Beer. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis.
Seth Lind是我们的运营总监。Emily Condon是我们的制作经理。Elise Begerson是我们的行政助理。Adrianne Mathiowetz运营我们的网站。研究帮助来自Michelle Harris和Julie Beer。音乐帮助来自Damien Graef和Rob Geddis。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's cofounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, I got a frantic call from him today. He had a big decision he needed help with.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交流中心交付给公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人，Torey Malatia先生。你知道，我今天接到了他一个紧急电话。他有一个重大的决定需要帮助。
Do I or don't I want to put on stilettos and a bikini and be in that music video?
我到底要不要穿上细高跟鞋和比基尼出现在那个音乐录影带里？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Ira Glass。下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。